PRESID AND JOE BIDEN IS
ALREAD PREPARING FOR HIS SECOND
MULTIT LEGISLATIVE
PUSH.
HE MADE IT CLEAR YESTERDAY THAT
HIS PRIORITY TO HELP THE
AMERIC ECONOMY NOW IS
INFRAS
HE TEASED AN ANNOUNCEMENT THAT
THIS NEXT MASSIVE PLAN WILL
INCLUD
LISTEN
>> IT'S THE PLACE WHERE WE WILL
INCREA AMERICAN PRODUCTIVITY
THE SAME TIME PROVIDING REALLY
GOOD JOBS FOR PEOPLE.
BUT WE CAN'T BUILD BACK TO WHAT
THEY USED TO BE.
>> CNN HAS MORE ON WHAT COULD BE
IN THE PLANS WITH CHRISTINE
ROMANS
>> THE NEXT BIG PRIORITY FOR
THIS WHITE HOUSE IS BUILDING
STUFF, A LOT OF STUFF.
ROADS, BRIDGES, RAILS, PORTS,
INVEST DOMESTIC
MANUFA
AND TECHNOLOGY AS WELL, EV
CHARGI STATIONS, 5-G CELLULAR
NETWOR AND CYBER DEFENSES.
THE PRESIDENT VOWING TO PUT
AMERIC TO WORK AND MAKING THE
U.S. M COMPETITIVE WITH
CHINA.
A CAMPAIGN PROMISE.
HE VOWED INVESTMENTES COULD
CREATE FIVE MILLION NEW JOBS AND
BRING BACK THE PANDEMIC JOBS
LOST.
THE ECONOMY, AS YOU KNOW, STILL
DOWN 9.5 MILLION JOBS SINCE
FEBRUA OF LAST YEAR.
INFRAS IS THE FIRST
PIECE.
THESECOND, QUALITY OF LIFE,
UNIVER PRE-K, MAKING THE
CHILD TAX CREDIT PERMANENT AND
PAID FAMILY LEAVE.
THE TRANSPORTAT SECRETARY
MAKING CASE ON THE HILL
THURSD FOR GREEN JRG
INVEST
CONGRE REPUBLICANS
WARNIN THE WHITE HOUSE KEEP THE
FOCUS ON ROADS AND BRIDGE ANDS
NOT CLIMATE CHANGE
JUSTIC
ALSO ON THE TABLE, HIGHER TAXES
FOR COMPANIES AND RICH TO PAY
FOR BIDEN AGENDA
FORESH THE POLITICAL
BATTLE AHEAD.
THE WHITE HOUSE WORKING OUT
DETAIL TO UNVEIL NEXT WEEK,
KATE, IN PITTSBURGH. CHRISTINE,
MUCH.
>>> JOINING ME RIGHT NOW FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE IS PRESIDENT
BIDEN' TOP ECONOMIST.
SHE CHAIR OF THE COUNCIL
OF ECONOMIC VISA
THANK  FOR BEING HERE.
INFRAS IS HIS NEXT
PRIORI
OUR REPORTING I IT COULD BE
MAYBE A $3 TRILLION PACKAGE.
ALREAD MITCH McCONNELL
RESPON THE PROSPECT OF IT
EVEN IS POSSIBLY A TROJAN HORSE
FOR MASSIVE TAX HIKES IS HOW HE
PUT IT.
WHAT W THIS WILL BE THE MOST
IMPORT PART OF THIS PACKAGE
TO CONVINCE PEOPLE IT'S NEEDED?
IS.  WILL WITH, LOOK, THE
PRESID FOCUS AT THE MOMENT
AND RIG HT IS GETTING PAST
THE PANDEMIC AND OUT OF THE
ECONOM HOLE THAT PANDEMIC
CAUSED
BUT AS HE STATED ON THE
CAMPAI IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO
JUST BUILD BACK TO WHERE WE WERE
BACK A YEAR AGO.
BUT WE HAVE TO DO BETTER BY THIS
ECONOM KNOW THAT THERE IS BADLY
NEEDED INVESTMENTS IN OUR
INFRAS IN R & D, AND
OUR WORKFORCE.
SO THIS ECONOMY REMAINS
COMPET AND SO THAT WE
INCREA PRODUCTIVIT AND AS HE
RIGHTL SAID, SO THAT WE
GENERA HIGH VALUE JOBS, JOBS
THAT ARE GOOD PAYING JOBS.
SO THAT IS THE PRESIDENT - THAT
IS THE FOCUS OF THE NEXT ROUND
OF HIS FOCUS AND WHAT WE'LL BE
WORKIN ON.
>> IN GENERAL, KIND OF LOOKING
AND TERMS OF THE RECOVERY, I
LOVE -- I WONDER WHERE YOU PUT
THE MARKER OF WHEN YOU'LL BE
COMFOR THAT LABOR MARKET
FULLY RECOVERED.
WHEN DO YOU EXPECT THAT TO BE?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, THEY HELP
ACCELE ALL OF THE FORECASTS
OF WHEN WE WILL BE GETTING BACK
ONTRACK.
AND SO NOW I EXPECT THAT WE'LL
BE AT FULL EMPLOYMENT SOME TIME
IN 2022, MAYBE AS EARLY AS THE
FIRST QUARTER OF 2022.
BUT IT'S NOT JUST ENOUGH FOR US
TO GET BACK TO AN AVERAGE
UNEMPL RATE THAT IS, YOU
KNOW, THE 3 OR 4%.
WE NEED TO BE ENSURING THAT
UNEMPL RATE IS ALSO COMING
DOWN FOR OUR AFRICAN-AMERICANS,
FOR OUR LATINOS, NATIVE-AMERICAN
POPULA
SO WE KNOW WE NEED TO BE DEALING
WITH OUR STRUCTURAL INEQUALITY
AS WELL.
BUT, YOU KNOW, I DO FULLY EXPECT
THAT, YOU KNOW, SOME TIME NEXT
YEAR THIS ECONOMY WILL BE COMING
ALONG.
>> AND ONE VERY UNEXPECTED NEW
THREAT TO ECONOMIES ACROSS THE
WORLD AND OURS IS THIS MASSIVE
SHIP THAT IS STUCK IN THE SUEZ
CANAL.
NOT ONLY IS IT AMAZING TO LOOK
AT, IT IS ALSO VERY SERIOUS IN
TERMS OF THE THREAT IT CAN
POSED.
HOW WORRIED YOU ARE ABOUT IT
IMPACT U.S. ECONOMY AND
RECOVE
>> WHAT THIS REFLECTS IS THIS
ECONOM IS NOT YET BACK.
WE ARE STILL IN A HOLE AS YOU
POINTE
9 1/2 MILLION JOBS IS BEEN LOST
OVER THE COURSE OF LAST YEAR AND
WE STILL HAVE A PANDEMIC.
THE PRESIDENT IS STILL FOCUSED.
THE NEW GOAL OF 200 MILLION
SHOTS AFTER 100 DAYS, SO WE KNOW
WE STILL HAVE WORK TO DO ON THE
PANDEM
UNTIL WE GET TO THE OTHER SIDE,
THE ECONOMY WILL BE FRAGILE.
THIS SHIP IS HIGHLIGHTIN HOW,
YOU KNOW, INTERCONNECTED WE ARE,
HOW HICCUPS IN OUR GLOBAL
ECONOM AND OUR SUPPLY CHAIN CAN
HAVE RIPPLE EFFECTS THROUGHOUT,
YOU KNOW, ECONOMIES AROUND THE
WORLD.
SO WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT IT.
WE'RE WATCHING IT.
AND I THINK IT JUST HIGHLIGHTS,
AGAIN, HOW IMPORTANT THE
AMERIC RESCUE PLAN WAS AND HOW
OUR FAMILIES NEEDED THE
ADDITI INCOME WITH THE
CHECKS HOW THE SUPPORT FOR
CHILDR THROUGH THE CHILD TAX
CREDIT AND THE EXPANSION
CHILDC OPENING SCHOOLS SO
THAT WOMEN CAN GET BACK TO WORK
IN PARTICULAR.
THAT W BE BOLSTERING
OUR OWN ECONOMY.
WE'RE NOT QUITE THERE YET.
>> I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT O
INSPEC OF THE COVID-19 RELIEF
PACKAG THAT I'M FASCINATED BY,
THE CHILD TAX CREDIT.
YOU HAVE UP TO $3600 PER CHILD
UNDER THE AGE OF 6.
SLIGHT LESS.
BUT STILL AN INCREASE FOR KIDS,
THAN THAT NUMBER FOR KIDS OLDER
THAN 6.
AND EVEN FAMILIES WITHOUT AN AN
INCOME%
INCOME RECEIVE A TAX
CREDIT
THIS WILL BE TRANSFORMTIV IN
REDUCI CHILD POVERTY.
HOW AND WHEN WILL YOU KNOW IF IT
WORKED
>> WELL, THAT'S AN INTERESTING
QUESTI
SO, YES, THE GROUP OF
RESEAR ESTIMATED THAT FIVE
MILLIO FEWER CHILDREN WILL BE
LIVING IN POVERTY AS A RESULT OF
THE PACKAGE THROUGH THE AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN.
THE WAY THAT POVERTY NUMBERS ARE
COLLEC THEY ARE LAGGED BY A
YEAR.
BUT I THINK WE WILL BE ABLE TO
SEE IT FAMILIES BEING ABLE TO
PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE AND PAY
RENT AND CLOTHES TO WEAR AND
THRIVI
I THIN IN THE DAY
TO DAY MORE QUICKLY THAN
THE POVERTY STIGS%
>> WHEN WILL FAMILIES START TO
SEE THE MONEY?
>> I THINK THEY ALREADY SENT OUT
100 MULLON CHECKS.
SO THE CHECKS ARE ALREADY
ARRIVI AND ON THE CHILD TAX
CREDIT
THE TREASURY DEPARTMENT IS
WORKIN OUT A WAY FOR IT TO BE
PAID ON A REGULAR BASIS SO THAT
FAMILI DON'T HAVE TO WAIT
UNTIL THE END OF THE TAX SEASON
NEXT YEAR IN ORDER TO SEE THAT
RELIEF
>> THAT IS WHAT I WAS CURIOUS
ABOUT HOW THAT WOULD WORK WITH
THE TA
IN YOUR VIEW, DO YOU THINK THIS
SHOULD BECOME PERMANENT, THE
CHILD TAX CREDIT?
OR DO YOU THINK THAT IT SHOULD
JUST BE PART OF AN EMERGENCY
ECONOM RECOVERY EFFORT FOR THE
COUNTR IN THIS MOMENT THAT
WE'RE IN RIGHT NOW?
>> LOOK, CHILD POVERTY IS --
REDUCI CHILD POVERTY IS PART
OF INVESTING IN OUR SOCIETY.
WE KNOW THAT CHILDREN WHO GROW
UP IN POVERTY ARE MORE LIKELY TO
BE HELD BACK IN SCHOOL.
THEY'R LIKELY TO GRADUATE
FROM HIGH SCHOOL.
THEY'R MORE LIKELY TO BE TEEN
PARENT
AND SO WE KNOW THAT INVESTING IN
CHILDC KIDS THAT ARE IN
POVERT ARE LESS HEALTHY.
SO, YES, WE BELIEVE THAT THIS IS
A TRANATIVE INVESTMENT IN
OUR KIDS.
THE WANTS TO WORK WITH
CONGRE
THERE ARE MANY WAYS TO DO SO BUT
WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH CONGRESS
TO SEE THAT HAPPEN.
>> MORE BROADLY KIND OF ON THE
APPROA OF THE WHITE HOUSE TO
ECONOM RECOVERY.
LARRY SUMMERS IS SPEAKING OUT
AGAIN AND HE REALLY CRITICIZED
THE MACROIMPACT OF THE ECONOMIC
POLICY SAYING HE THINKS THIS IS
THE LEAST RESPONSIBLE
MACROE POLICY THAT WE
HAVE HAD IN THE LAST 40 YEARS.
DOES THIS -- DOES THAT
ASSESS FROM LARRY SUMMERS
GIVE YOU PAUSE ABOUT POTENTIALLY
SPENDI AND BORROWING TRILLIONS
MORE?
>> WELL, LOOK.
YOU KNOW, WE -- LARRY SUMMERS IS
CONCER ABOUT THE AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN IN PARTICULAR.
AND HE IS CONCERNED THAT IT IS
LARGER THAN WHAT WAS NECESSARY
TO ADDRESS THE ECONOMIC SHORT
FALL RIGHT NOW.
WE -- LARRY IS, YOU KNOW, IS
SOMEON THAT HIS CONCERN THAT HE
RAISED OUR CONCERNS, WE'RE
AWARE OF THEM.
WE ASSESS THE PROBLEM
DIFFER
WE SEE THAT THERE IS POTENTIAL
RISK FOR INFLATION.
BUT THE RISK OF DOING TOO LITTLE
IN TERMS OF GENERATING ECONOMIC
SCARRI HAVING FAMILIES THAT
CAN'T FOOD ON THE TABLE, THE
IMPACT FOR CHILDREN WHICH WE
JUST DISCUSSED WAS FAR GREATER
THAN THE POTENTIAL IMPACT ON
INFLAT
IMPORT THE FEDERAL